credit ratings agency Moody says Russia
may be in default on its sovereign debt
if it doesn't correct course and make
two recent payments in dollars instead
of rubles Russia made the payments in
question earlier this month both were on
dollar denominated bonds Moody said that
settlement with rubles breaches the
terms of the contracts and would put
Russia in default if the same payments
aren't made in dollars by May 4th
a currency is also at the heart of a
dispute between Russia and the EU
overpayments for Russian energy on
Thursday President Vladimir Putin
threatened again to turn off energy
flows to the EU if member states don't
pay for gas in Rubles something they so
far have refused to do
speaking at a televised government
meeting on Thursday Putin said that
European firms could be considered in
default on their payments
the EU has emphasized that delivery
contracts call for dollar or Euro
payments a Putin also said Moscow was
seeking new markets for its energy as
Europe tries to end Russian Imports
we need to diversify the exports
we will assume that energy supplies to
the West will decrease in the
foreseeable future
therefore it is important to seal the
trend of recent years to redirect our
exports step by step towards
fast-growing markets in the south and
east
all right TW business reporter Arthur
Sullivan joins me here in studio for
more
um Arthur Putin there talking about
directing energy elsewhere where exactly
is he referring to most likely and have
we seen any efforts so far to do just
that yeah he mentioned Stephen the the
South and the East and Russia's context
that really means two countries China
and India and really and truly Russia's
energy Alternative Energy Ambitions
begin and end with China with I would
say a more aspirational tilt towards
India the reasons are obvious those two
countries together combine almost you
know 2.8 billion of the world's people
they are two of the top three energy
consumers in the world they're obvious
markets to Target however in terms of
what we've seen so far we have seen
India buying slightly more oil from
Russia since the invasion because
they've been able to get it at a
discount a significant discount it's
still not not much relatively speaking a
lot less than Europe uses obviously and
in terms of China we have seen you know
rhetoric and talk of of New Deals I mean
for example in February they announced a
new gas pipeline but again the amounts
involved are relatively modest so no so
far we haven't seen enough evidence to
suggest anything in a more in a
substantial way okay so the aspirations
Russia's aspirations are potentially
high but it sounds like it's not very
realistic that they can actually shift
away or replace the EU as a customer
exactly an easy way to look at this is
we focus a lot on how much Europe's
depend on Russian gas look at how much
Russia has been dependent on Europe as a
customer roughly three quarters of
Russia's natural gas exports in recent
times have gone to Europe half its oil
has gone to Europe that's a huge Market
to try and replace in terms of
realistically replacing that with those
markets in China and India look at
what's involved so for example gas gas
pipelines take years to be developed and
built there are some you know pardon the
pawn in the pipeline but this is just
not nowhere near the volume that goes to
Europe in terms of oil yes it's more
movable it can it's easier to move
around but again these countries China
and India they have long-standing
relationships with Middle Eastern
Partners they get their oil from Saudi
Arabia they get their oil from the UAE
they may see those as more stable stable
sources and they're not necessarily
going to upend those relationships
simply to have a better relationship
with the crownliner with Vladimir Putin
so no it's it's difficult to see it in a
long-term sense all right DW businesses
Arthur Sullivan in studio thank you very
much
well Arthur mentioned those recent
purchases of Russian gas by I'm sorry
Russian oil I should say by India
actions that have caused friction with
Western and G7 Nations leading the
sanctions against Moscow Delhi has thus
far stuck struck a very defiant tone
against warnings from the U.S for
example but how sustainable is its
position
India has maintained close relations
with Russia for decades the Asian
countries not just a key customer for
Russian consumer goods but weapons are
also high up on the list of imports
especially aircraft tanks and frigates
sixty percent of India's arms Imports
come from Russia India hasn't sanctioned
Russia over the war and Ukraine quite
the opposite at the end of March New
Delhi seized the opportunity to buy
Russian oil at a deep discount and is
considering further orders despite calls
from the U.S not to do so if you're
looking at energy purchases from Russia
I would suggest that your attention
should be focused on Europe I suspect
looking at the figures probably our
total purchases for the month would be
less than what Europe does in an
afternoon Russian gas coal and cooking
oil could also be exported to India soon
foreign minister Sergey lavrov sought to
strengthen trade ties when he visited
Delhi at the beginning of April
uh we will be ready to supply to India
any uh Goods which India wants to buy
preferably paid in Indian rupees or
Russian rubles lavrov edit to help break
the dominance of the US dollar
maintaining a partnership with Russia
while not alienating the West it's going
to be a difficult line to tread for
India
charukartikai is our correspondent in
Delhi Charo The Narrative here is often
that Delhi is walking a very fine line
how is this issue seen over there in
India
well yes even uh Delhi is indeed walking
a fine line you know the government of
India has condemned the war but it has
not condemned Russia uh the government
condemned the killings in butcher in
Ukraine but it did not condemn the
Russian forces or even the Russian
president for that matter so yes it's a
tightrope walk that the Indian
government is attempting to do at this
point of time and ever since uh the War
Began that's because it has its
interests in mind in India you know
experts are divided in their opinion on
as as to what should linear Stan be
right now there is a section of uh
analysts who look at foreign policy
who've been saying that this is a
quandary and it is actually
disappointing for a country that aspires
to become a global superpower for not to
be taken a clear-cut stand against
against war and and an aggressive
country but then there is a certain
section of experts as well who believe
that India is doing what many other
nations all are also doing which is
safeguarding their own interests Stephen
at the same time India is seeing these
Rising fuel prices as are many countries
around the world how disruptive can that
be for society in India
it's a very problematic situation right
now uh Stephen uh oil prices uh have
been going up uh significantly there
have been at least 13 oil price hikes so
far the prices of vehicle fuel have gone
up and petrol and Diesel as well as CNG
and these always tend to have a
cascading effect on the economy because
of the because of the transportation
cost that is involved in transporting
goods from one part of the country to
another so often these lead and as they
are leading right now to a rise in
prices of other Commodities as well and
especially food so that always becomes a
pressure point for for the government
because then eventually it when it when
it comes to sort of a boiling point then
pressures then protests begin so far
widespread protests have not been seen
on the streets of the country so far but
then the opposition parties they are
riled and they've they have they they've
been organizing symbol protests against
the price hike so that's of course a
very tricky situation for the government
to handle all right so perhaps added
incentive there to search for that cheap
Russian oil I want to ask Deli Delhi has
pointed out the Delhi government has
pointed out that Europe is of course
still buying massive amounts of Russian
energy should European countries manage
to agree on fossil fuel sanctions
against Russia could that in theory put
more pressure on India to do the same
briefly if you could
I think Stephen yes that is a
possibility that might increase the
pressure on India but I think what will
increase the pressure further on India
will will be the day when Europe will
stop taking Russian gas because uh
that's what the uh foreign minister s
Jai Shankar has always been alluding to
that European while European continues
continue countries continue to do
business with Russia they cannot be
sermonizing India against uh doing so so
when Europe stops doing with Russia that
will be the day when India will find it
hard to uh to to uh to provide to to
submit arguments as to why it continues
it's really business relationship but
then even in spite of that there is a
significant amount of dependence on
Russia for a lot of Defense as well as
business needs so it remains to be seen
where uh how long India will be able to
resist this pressure and continue this
tightrope walk Stephen all right in
Delhi thank you very much
and with the EU discussing those
possible oil sanctions against Russia
the search for replacement sources is
leading member states like Germany to
reconsider once taboo Alternatives such
as Drilling in the North Sea so could
Iran be an eventual partner for new
Imports that might be easier said than
done
these oil Platforms in Iranian waters
are working around the clock the
government in Tehran doesn't publish
official figures on how much oil the
country exports but estimates suggest
that sales abroad have fallen somewhere
between 50 and 90 percent that's due to
U.S sanctions first put in place in 2018
before the sanctions an estimated 4.5
million barrels left Iran for the
foreign market each day while the U.S
has sanctioned sales the European Union
has not but the U.S measures are enough
to scare off almost any company that
purchases Iranian oil
in order for Germany to buy Iranian
crude oil it is necessary for the U.S to
lift their sanctions on shipping
companies crude oil and financial
transactions with Iran
at the moment no European shipping
company wants to transport Iranian oil
with its tankers no refinery in Europe
wants to process the oil and no
International Bank wants to handle the
payment the fear of penalties on the
lucrative U.S market is too great
Iran sells most of its exported oil to
China rather than use currency Iran and
China have agreed to an oil for goods
deal a kind of barter transaction yet
Iran hardly needs Chinese Goods machines
from Europe would be much more important
for the economy of a country with a
population of 83 million
Iran
especially has a huge problem with
foreign exchange if this crude oil is
sold via International payments then you
naturally have foreign exchange and you
can make better use of Foreign Exchange
if you're able to import other products
the latest nuclear negotiations with
Iran which could end the U.S sanctions
have made progress but the remaining
points of contention are tough on one
side Tehran insists that the Iran's
revolutionary guards no longer be
classified as a terrorist organization
but for the U.S this is a red line
also at the negotiating table is Russia
and Russia is not interested in making
it easier for Iranian oil to replace
Russian oil in the global market
[Music]